[Musique]
bonsoir j'ai mal au ventre
le stress le stress de l'étudiant qui
attend dans le couloir devant la porte
de la salle d'examen
nous sommes le vendredi 18 avril 2008 je
suis à nairobi au kenya dans les
installations de médecins sans
frontières où je termine une mission
d'une semaine sur le terrain et je
travaille pour la xm fois ma
présentation qui s'intitule ma vision du
cetic à 50
un mois plus tôt
rentré chez moi après le boulot je
reçois un coup de téléphone de mon
directeur de l'époque
à ce moment là je dirigeais une équipe
d'une dizaine de personnes au cetic le
centre d'excellence en technologies de
l'information et la communication
un centre de recherche basé à charleroi
qui travaillent pour les autres les
entreprises informatiques de la région
il me demande si on peut se voir après
le travail vont conclu très rapidement
d'un endroit à namur on se retrouve dans
une brasserie est arrivé sur place il
n'y va pas par quatre chemins et
m'annonce qu'il vient de démissionner de
son poste de directeur et que le conseil
d'administration a proposé de me confier
la direction du centre
la nouvelle me tombe dessus je vais
avoir 30 ans est un fameux défi je
rentre chez moi et par hasard je reçois
un appel skype d'un ami professeur à
l'école de technologie supérieure de
montréal et j'en profite pour lui
expliquer ce qui m'est proposé il est
très direct il me dit simon une
opportunité comme ça à ton âge tu n'en
auras pas deux je ne réfléchis pas
beaucoup plus longtemps je dors dessus
j'accepte un mois plus tard je deviens
directeur du cetic qui occupe à l'époque
40 personnes
je pense que cet événement constitue la
première prise de risque de ma carrière
cinq ans plus tard
ça fait dix ans plus ou moins que je
suis au cetic à ce moment là et je
travaille au quotidien avec les
entreprises ayant un manque qui
néanmoins envie d'aller plus loin
d'aller au delà de la recherche et du
développement de passer dans la création
de produits dans lancements de produits
et il se fait que juste avant le congé
de noël
on est en 2012 je reçois un coup de
téléphone
un chasseur de têtes qui est mandaté par
un entrepreneur liégeois qui recherche
un directeur pour un incubateur et fonds
d'investissement qu'il veut lancer sur
liège
mon rêve cet entrepreneur il s'agit de
pierre l'ouest le fondateur d'une
entreprise bien connue basé à liège qui
est devenu leader mondial dans les
ralentis tv qui occupe plus de 400
personnes dans le monde au travers de 15
office et qui est à 90% parts de marché
et le projet en question s'appelle et
baptisé la factory en clin d'oeil à
l'artiste qu'il apprécie
particulièrement ndi warhol dont
l'atelier à new york avait été également
baptisé du même nom l'ambition c'est de
créer c'est un incubateur et fonds
d'investissements et donc en deux mois
un incubateur c'est un endroit où on va
accueillir des porteurs de projets pour
les encadrer les aider à lancer leur
entreprise
le projet est fantastique c'est un
véritable challenge
une feuille blanche un projet à
construire cette fois ci pas besoin
d'appels skype je fonce je pars à liège
si je m'arrête un instant et je regarde
en arrière pour regarder
l'élément central le commun dénominateur
de tout ça je pense que c'est la
curiosité
en effet à la sortie de mes humanités
j'hésite entre deux voies
d'une part l'histoire qui me passionne
depuis ma plus tendre enfance et
l'informatique je suis tombé dans le
monde des pc époux de l'internet et les
deux m'intéresse je choisi de démarrer
par l'histoire en écoutant les conseils
de mes parents qui m'explique le
parcours universitaire est assez
difficile et que la passion devrait
l'adoucir ce qui fut effectivement le
cas
et me voilà ici à l'université de namur
pour démarrer mais candidature alors ce
qui est intéressant dans l'histoire
c'est que c'est une discipline très 360
degrés parce qu'elle va faire appel
elle-même a plein d'autres disciplines à
la philosophie la psychologie
l'assistance la sociologie les sciences
économiques
la statistique le droit bref autant de
manières d'appréhender le monde et sa
réalité qui m'aident encore aujourd'hui
je poursuis par une licence par ma
licence à louvain la neuve et là j'ai la
chance de travailler sur un sujet qui me
passionne encore aujourd'hui la première
guerre mondiale et en particulier
l'invasion doute 14 ma licence terminé
je reviens à namur pour démarrer une
licence en informatique et deux ans
après me voilà avec mes deux diplômes en
main et cette fois ci il faut choisir et
se lancer dans le monde professionnel et
je pars dans l'informatique le côté
tangi pragmatique des technologies
m'attire et je démarre au cetic le
centre de recherche dont je vous parlais
qui venait d'être créée
on est alors une équipe de cinq
chercheurs à l'époque également en
quelque sorte un peu en mode start up
avec certes un peu moins de risques et
je vais démarrer comme chercheur en
qualité logicielle puis je vais avoir
différentes opportunités travaillent sur
des projets régionaux pays européens
dans d'autres technologies le grid le
cloud computing donc des technologies
que l'on connaît tous aujourd'hui
puisqu'elles sont sur nos téléphones
portables et nous nos ordinateurs et des
projets qui vont faire rencontrer pas
mal de monde
en europe alors dans ce parcours je vais
être aussi confronté à l'échec puisque
je vais lancer avec un collègue un
projet de start up qui pourtant très
ambitieux très noble idée c'était de
concevoir et commercialiser un compagnon
digital pour faciliter le maintien à
domicile des personnes âgées
malheureusement le produit va être lancé
trop tôt dans un marché qui ne sera pas
mature beaucoup d'amertume sur le moment
mais énormément de leçons apprises qui
me servent encore aujourd'hui
et justement le risque
l'incertitude ce sont des éléments qui
sont mon quotidien à la factory alors la
factory nous sommes donc incubateur
accélérateur et fonds d'investissements
pour start up technologiques on cherche
des projets qui se construit sur des
technologies de rupture qui vont pouvoir
être développée à l'échelle
internationale l'élément fondamental qui
guide notre processus
ce sont les fondateurs les fondateurs de
projets des fondateurs de start-up des
passionnés des gens qui sont légitimes
dans leurs technologies pour qui ce
projet d'entreprise est vraiment
l'élément central de leur vie là qui ont
la hargne qui ont la volonté de le faire
aboutir
alors je parle de fondateurs ou pluriel
parce qu'effectivement cette aventure de
start up est un parcours qui va être
semé d'embûches de difficultés de
risques d'incertitudes et de
questionnement et le fait d'avoir des
duos facilite ce travail parce que les
fondateurs peuvent échanger peuvent
partager vos tentes ils sont face à des
difficultés alors notre travail à la
factory c'est d'une part d'investir donc
d'amener du capital élément nécessaire
mais non suffisant pour lancer une
entreprise
l'essentiel de notre travail c'est
surtout d'encadrer de conseiller les
porteurs de projets dans le des points
fondamentaux comme la stratégie
commerciale la stratégie de
développement produit la constitution
d'une équipe
parce que ce qui est essentiel dans une
start up c'est la qualité d'exécution
c'est la rapide et la rapidité
d'exécution
parce qu'on est dans un monde qui
aujourd'hui est connecté un monde qui
est globalisée et donc la concurrence va
très vite et leur ennemi numéro un
c'est le temps par conséquent notre
attention est portée sur vraiment les
éléments qui leur permet d'aller vite
pour atteindre le premier palier alors
il y a un projet dont j'ai envie de vous
parler ce soir parce que je vis il me
tient particulièrement à coeur
il s'agit des peas c'est une start-up
que nous avons soutenu qui est issu de
l'université de louvain d'un laboratoire
en micro électronique spécialisé dans la
gestion de la très basse consommation
des composants électroniques et leur
ambition c'est de remplacer les
batteries sont les objets connectés
vous savez que dans le domaine de
l'internet des objets pour vous donner
un chiffre
on annonce à l'horizon 2020 plus de 30
milliards d'objets connectés
si on continue à les alimenter avec des
batteries comme on le fait aujourd'hui
on va se trouver confronté à un énorme
problème de gestion de déchets le modèle
n'est pas tenable alors que autour de
nous on a le soleil on à la chaleur on a
le mouvement on a les ondes radio qui
peuvent être utilisés pour les alimenter
et c'est ça tout le génie de cette
société de leur technologie alors les
deux fondateurs qui était issu de ce
laboratoire avait très vite émis leur
envie de créer une start up pour
exploiter cette technologie mais il
avait été confronté à la difficulté est
au retour de certaines autorités qui
leur disaient qu'elle est très bonne
idée mais lancer une entreprise c'est
quelque chose de sérieux il faut des
managers expérimentés des managers aux
cheveux blancs pour reprendre
l'expression qu'ils avaient entendu et
geoffroy un des deux co fondateurs un
peu dépité mais toujours bien motivés
mangeant soir du printemps 2014 avec un
de mes amis à qui ils se confient il
explique sa difficulté trouver du
capital et un environnement dans lequel
il va pouvoir être accompagnés pour
lancer son projet la mise en relation
est très vite fait avec la factory
quelques mois plus tard ils nous
rejoignent et nous allons les incubés
pendant un peu plus de 18 mois
les aider a lancé l'entreprise
structurer l'équipe pour atteindre
l'année dernière un premier palier
essentiel la commercialisation de leur
premier produit
et puis en juillet dernier une très
belle levée de fonds de plus de 3
millions d'euros avec des partenaires de
premier rang au niveau international
hippies et maintenant à une nouvelle
étape et peut continuer son
développement
alors il ya quelques éléments qui
rétrospectivement géant que j'ai envie
de partager avec vous par rapport à mon
parcours
le premier qui concerne justement cette
notion d'entrepreneurs je suis convaincu
que ce n'est pas un rôle ou un état qui
est réservé à certains une à une élite
on a tous en nous des gènes
d'entrepreneurs qui ne demande qu'à
s'exprimer avec différentes intensités
selon les projets l'élément clé c'est la
curiosité c'est l'empathie par rapport
au monde qui nous entoure la capacité
d'observer pour identifier des
opportunités
c'est ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui dans
mon travail j'ai la chance d'être en
quelque sorte un découvreur de talents
ou un facilitateur d'intuition et ce que
je retiens c'est vraiment faites vous
confiance
suivez vos passions soyez curieux pour
trouver des opportunités les
opportunités de pouvoir sauter dans un
nouveau projet et puis surtout foncé je
vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]